die trinker schon dass es endlich weiter
bringen ist viel und so prächtig bei den
fahrten und nina und wie sind sie es die
raten dies ist aus diesen vier
tore 2 naja wie schafft sie locker
das team bei uns kann er dringt der
kurti sorge bringen
er hat toll wie sie sehen jetzt
superblade süße leben da ist
mittagspause
da steht ein wurf zeit 9 bis 12 und 14
bis 19 uhr
[Applaus]
das ist ja wirklich ist jetzt mit obama
wer der mann saß der industrie im radio
heim und davor dass dem die flaschen aus
ihrem haus
hallo mittagsruhe
und uns wirklich das ganze glücklich
nach hause eigentlich nicht stehen noch
mit otto ja
ist es jetzt ja grundlos oder braun glas
ist dieses
dieses grün frei grün ist genauso grün
wäre der haider zu wenig aber weiter zu
ihm sarah brown geben also ich sag dir
super noch harmlos ja nachahmer setzte
den kitas containern extrem trikot es
bei den herren kommen später schlafen
nach plan
hellgrün
dunkelgrün
[Musik]
moskaus
min penalty raus
der chef ist da unten
schaut doch jetzt kehrt der coach
[Applaus]